[Music]
we're seeing
more new referrals people who previously
didn't have mental health problems
a second pandemic i have struggled a lot
throughout this whole year
am i going to be infected and why people
around me going to be infected
a mental health crisis triggered by
covid19
since that first lockdown what we've
seen is a sustained increase in demand
on our crisis lines
a surge in cases pushing a struggling
system closer
to the edge for one reason or another
this young person
had decided enough is enough
we are hearing that people are
self-harming more
a coveted legacy that will impact lives
long after the pandemic is over
i am worried that we will see
repercussions of this for years to come
how long have you stopped your
medication
two days that's not too bad but please
as promised continue taking your
medication
and apart from this currency and apart
from this current situation
any other stressor you've got the calls
keep
coming this mental health crisis line
is manned 24 hours a day seven
days a week it needs to be one of the
support is your medication
which you require to help you to feel
better
from your depression and for you to look
into
what makes you feel better and what
makes you feel happy
so we can support you to attain your
goals
we work in crisis care so our job is
looking after people when they're going
through mental health crises and we look
after them
at home so we deal with people really at
quite a vulnerable point
dr derek tracy is the clinical director
for oxley's
he's responsible for adult mental health
in bexley in south east london
we are seeing more people contacting
services who have no
past experience with mental health care
people's stresses are up
people's resources are down so the
things you might do to help with that
ordinarily may be
you go for dinner with friends you can't
do that and then the services when you
go to contact them
are really busy so we're stretched
dr tracy's team are continuing to
support vulnerable people in the
community
it's to help them before they reach
crisis point
and need admitting into hospital i do
think we're going to have a surge in the
coming months
i think what's really hard to see is how
long that's going to last
and how deeply it's going to last
we've been given rare access to the
wards of a mental health unit
and to the teams of dedicated staff who
have worked through this emergency
how rare is it for you to have an
unoccupied bed
we always run close to full capacity and
that's something that is
being the case before the pandemic
that's not been altered in fact at the
start of the pandemic
we'd push to try discharge as many
people as we could out of an anxiety
that this would be an infection hub for
them
this adult mental health ward is almost
always
full but the numbers of patients being
admitted here
fell during the first wave but they are
rising
again many campaigners have warned that
britain's mental health services
have been neglected for too long through
years of underfunding
if the threatened explosion in mental
health cases
does happen it will push a struggling
system closer
to the edge here in southeast london in
kent they are beginning to see the start
of this surge since that first lockdown
what we've seen is a sustained increase
in demand on our crisis lines they're
still running about 30
above pre-pandemic levels but also more
and more people through their
gp asking for access to psychological
therapies
and our demand for that is up around 280
compared to pre-pandemic levels what
we've got to do is make sure that we
distinguish between
the natural response of feeling as
though this has been difficult
and people who through their own
resilience and through the support of
their friends and families will recover
and then those people who become unwell
and who need the help of the nhs with
that
and that is the group of patients we
really need to think about at the minute
and how we resource that
successive lockdowns are taking their
mental toll
not surprisingly the stress of isolation
compounded by anxiety over job losses
and the uncertainty over our futures is
to some extent
affecting us all but some people will
get support from family and friends
once the restrictions are eased
others might not be so resilient
dina will be looking out for these
people
using her own experiences to help others
struggling to cope it's been tough
um like with my own mental health
and obviously dealing with other
people's mental health
dina works for the mental health charity
mind
which in partnership with oxley's
provides community-based
support the uncertainty about what's
going to happen next
um is my job safe am i going to be
infected are my
people around me going to be infected
what's going to happen
like there's so much fear and that's
kind of played a part of my own
anxieties and how i'm going to
cope day to day dina's mental health
struggle began when she was just 13
years old
she's been getting much better but last
july went back on medication
this pandemic is affecting people with a
history of mental health problems
but also others who are experiencing
issues
for the first time we see people from
all walks of life
um there are people that have come
through to our services who have no
experience with mental health
difficulties it's all completely new to
them and like suddenly their whole world
has changed
and they're coming to terms with that as
well and plucking up the courage to be
able to ask for help
the first person emailed in to say um as
we're nearly a year into this pandemic
and whilst we have a vaccine and
infection numbers have started to fall
i'm finding life particularly hard at
the moment the pandemic has forced
mental health service providers to adapt
this therapy session has moved online
here people who were once service users
have re-trained to become counselors
like joanna
working alongside therapists like neil
many people who have severe anxiety
depression
or any of the other conditions like
personality disorder are used to
coping with quite difficult things so
actually they coped really really well
in the initial phases but as things have
gone on
the level of isolation the level of
disconnection from routine all of these
things are just
really accumulating anecdotally and we
are hearing that people are
self-harming more but people are just
using anything to just
try and manage thoughts and feelings
that they would normally do through just
being with
people you know and of course that's
gone do you tell them what your
experiences were
do yeah i can do oh you know i'm quite
selective it's knowing that
you can have this feeling and there is
another side to it like it can go away
and things can improve so when you're
you know when i was particularly unwell
i don't i'm not phrased but when i was
particularly unwell
it's really difficult to hold on to any
sort of light at the end of the tunnel
you think that is it you think this is
the way that life will be for you now
the center for mental health warns that
up to 10 million people
will need mental health support as a
direct consequence of covet 19.
alarmingly 1.5 million of these
are expected to be children and young
people
under 18. peter
and this is not his real name is a
schoolboy from
london he tells me he's had some issues
with his mental health in the past
but the pandemic is making his obsessive
compulsive disorder
worse if you have a compulsion that
just simply involves door handles
but the pandemic the the problem the
issue with the pandemic is that it kind
of
gives you more time to think things
through
and because of that you start to maybe
think oh um
maybe there's something wrong with light
switches as well and then all of a
sudden it's like
you've got little things popping up here
and there and then if you don't
if you if you're not able to stop them
in their tracks early on
early on and they can develop further
and become worse and worse have they
developed
further have they become worse in my
case
i would say yes however
i'm working with my clinicians and
hopefully we can come up with some sort
of plans
now because of the pandemic or i haven't
got anywhere to go
you kind of get more time to play with
your own thoughts and because you have
faults popping into your head
you don't really get a chance to combat
them and does that
lead to you being overwhelmed with these
thoughts
yes it leads to an overwhelming
sensation
and then that's what then triggers the
compulsion
dr omar mugrabbi is peter's consultant
he told me he's seeing a sharp spike in
cases
and some were very worrying we've seen
an increased amount of activity within
our crisis services whether it's by
telephone or
of our crisis line that's that their
numbers of
people have spoken just skyrocketed um
in the last year or so
um and as and we've been extremely busy
in the a e department
of young people that we're seeing in
there i've seen a couple of young people
who've presented to
a e who have taken overdoses
um who've cut themselves severely
some who've changed their patterns of
eating um so severely that they've lost
a lot of weight that our colleagues
medical colleagues are treating them
medically in order to save their lives
what's driving this
one can only say the major factor across
all of it is the pandemic
it's not just the young who are affected
the elderly are particularly vulnerable
too
with some clinicians warning of a trauma
time bomb it's the same as
everything else the longer you leave it
and the worse it's likely to get now
that's
true of cancer but it's equally true
of mental health
this is exactly what dr fadipe is seeing
in her ward she specializes in the care
of elderly patients with dementia even
inside here
the effect of the pandemic can be felt
during the first week i think families
were a bit worried
about people coming to hospitals they're
presenting themselves now
we've seen an increased referrals and
we've seen the people are much
worse and it's this pause in seeking
treatment that will have serious
consequences
any kind of intervention that we would
have put in as an early intervention
then doesn't work so you need to use
something different which means they may
spend a longer period of time
in hospital you may have to use more
medication than you would have usually
used um and you may have to they may
lose the opportunity to be able to go
back home
how worried are you about the long-term
impact
of the pandemic on the mental health of
elderly patients with dementia the
prevalence of dementia was increasing
anyway
due to various factors but isolation
leading to
low mood and depression can be a
precipitator for developing dementia
a lack of activities which we've all
seen in lockdown
can lead to or can precipitate dementia
so i am worried
that we will see repercussions of this
for years to come
this stark warning from dr fadibe is
being sounded
by other mental health care workers
across the country
britain's mental health crisis is in
danger
of becoming a legacy of the pandemic
i don't think we should rush too quickly
to try to decide what impact
lockdown and pandemics had on people's
mental health we need to give
the staff in the nhs who've been through
a lot the time to talk about their
experiences and absorb that
what we've all experienced a lot of
problems will go underground and will
manifest
a bit later i'm optimistic that in a
post-pandemic world a lot of it's going
to settle down
but i think there are some people that
this is going to be a problem that
they're going to carry with them through
their lives